just whatever the next language is I was
just talking to somebody using a lick
sir I've never used a lick sir but they
were like super excited about it
so yeah that's like I don't I don't know
but I would like I think I can write the
C code well enough to be
high-performance and exposed sort of and
may get get the hard parts right
with timezone handling etc and make that
a core that everyone else can like tap
into so we don't need to rewrite the
same logic and get it wrong over and
over I mean this has been in heavy
production for I don't know a decade
more than a decade but it's like it's it
is used globally everywhere it's kind of
weird it's super weird but and I only
paid for any of it but that's annoying
yeah but no consequently it's I think
yeah I mean it's like correct yeah so
yeah I mean I the performance of KDB is
fantastic and but if you combine I have
versions of this too like if you combine
the xes semantics and not so much the
logic is it doesn't quite work that way
the out of course stuff but with then
and actually k DB doesn't work out
before anyway or maybe maybe it does now
but it didn't used to like it all needs
to be in memory but like those two
things are pretty easy to marry even in
like example code that I could write
like right now I'm using MF so like the
whole I'd really like low-level pieces
and so I think my mental model is
getting smaller and smaller like if I
can make very small libraries that we
can stitch together and I sort of build
like an ecosystem around them that's
where I want to be I think that's what's
future wise like if I try and write
another whatever if I make X dance
better it's gonna benefit what seems to
be a smaller and smaller maybe it's not
smaller of a relatively smaller
community and that just seems like a
dumb idea
so like I'd rather have something that
you know XDS can still will attach to
and write and go forward with and make
everyone who uses it better but also
people who Python or Julie
or kdb and so that's kind of the idea
yeah are they small they all important
like 75 packages but they all work
really just when you have 85 so that
actually was yeah I think somewhere in
there's like that was literally I went
to Kurt invited me out to Vienna in oh 9
and he was like this is a bad idea like
you can't just pop like polluted the
namespace in the global environment and
I was like you are totally right he's
like if you want to do that load is what
like load in R is exactly what does that
like that's how you pollute those global
environment or any environment
defaulting to the global environment but
he's like get is the function that
returns the values like you are correct
and I'm kind of annoyed that I screwed
that up so that's where that message
comes from I just don't like to break
things so I kind of let it go you could
you can use the load run and you can set
the toggle and be like you know just the
fact that you ignore the warning tells
me a lot about you so for what is like a
decade so I don't know what to tell you
this is more than just this is not a
question to me this is maybe like a
therapist question
if anybody has any like again the tidy
verse stuff or anything that seems to be
useful to like you would like to tell me
about or complain to me about
yeah I think I mean it's definitely a
highlight depending upon the time series
the guy next to you might be probably
the most plausible he knows more than
anyone else
certainly the room possibly on earth I
don't think there's a it's kind of like
rolling futures kind of thing like a lot
like there's no I don't think there's a
canonical way to do it there maybe there
is but it's probably the wrong way
frankly like it's just there's no
there's no one solution which I guess
it's kind of good in finance space but
but no I mean XDS will do something this
kind of standard range type thing and it
allows you to do whatever arbitrary
function you would like and generally
speaking it's all musingly it's all
written in Fortran which is kind of
crazy yeah I believe I have one of the
most like deployed code bases of Fortran
on earth just because of the stupidity
of me writing it whatever it is 12 years
ago in portraying some of this stuff so
that's nothing to be really
oh I'm sure another no like certainly in
like ok anything like that yeah but like
one of I do not that many of them is my
guess fixed like Chicago fixed
[Music]
[Laughter]
- yes thank you very much thank you I
was gonna say I've watched people get
these over the years and I'm always been
jealous but this is bad I didn't even
think about this until I saw him today I
was like oh my gosh you're thinking yeah
one who's back this Adam Hogan would
love this title for me by the way he
sends me something like that all the
time when I am swearing about something
to him yes exactly
wow this is fantastic thank you for
coming
parallelism which would make it
competitive with the Julia slide that
was one of those checkboxes that'd be
pretty trivial so we should do that
bigger the memory and map which actually
M map is what I wanted to talk about
tonight Derek talked me down from it but
in math I wrote but I just really liked
it so no actually I'm Memphis yeah
forget forget you I'm just gonna talk
about it for a second and that provides
this like very basic low level system
call to end that but also gives you like
high-level rappers too are so you could
say like and map this integer vector
whereas in Python if you try and do that
you're dealing with bytes because
what I'm at does so MFN are provides
this like ability even like instruct
Struck's in like CD struck so you can
share data back and forth you do
arbitrary types you can do it's it's
very very well that it's also updated a
lot once a year
what are you just added in big-endian
support for a guy who's doing some data
it's like astronomy data yeah I don't
know what it was about it but so there
he gave me a sample and I made it work
but I but that can be applied here
trivially or the altar up stuff that's
coming or is kind of in available at
this point a lot more C code native of
nanosecond supports I don't actually
care about nanoseconds but a lot of
people do but and it should be it should
be there it's kind of dumb it's not and
then also one thing we played with was
this the idea like all of the kind of
fanciness of dealing with time like if
you could just put that in a in a vector
and get that for free inside of a
dataframe or whatever else you wanted to
put it in a tipple tip all right I like
when I have these here next time I come
I'm gonna require but yeah so but it
should just be it should be a native x
time series kind of thing which also has
code behind it so one day but then I got
to thinking like what if this is
actually the you know sort of a reason
I'm here but it's the reason I what I
what really is driving me at this moment
in time what if this is like bigger than
X yes I kind of feel like we live in a
world now that is post language not to
be I love our so I continue these are
but I'm sure there's a lot of people
here use Python I use Python maybe
someone here who's been here maybe over
time who uses Julia and then but there's
just a bunch of ways to use this and
right now they're kind of all their own
victims so I was thinking like man if we
could do all of that stuff plus what
we've done before and then do it in you
know like
cross-platform see and under a license
that won't be crushed by Amazon I you
know I think that would be neat so I
kind of know I like that's a really
interesting idea and I was thinking like
yes this needs to happen so this is my
this is my plan and I'm not very good
Photoshop but I do believe I did a
pretty good job on this one yeah thanks
a lot a lot of new skills learned in
that one so that Wow look at that I know
that's pretty good well what else would
you expect I would like to know a
kolache question yeah I know I do I
always have questions oh wait actually
there's a legitimate question over there
yeah so that one is the sorry belt I'm
Trey oh is that one yeah yeah there's a
whole bunch of those too
yeah what's the representation that they
do for its effectively I think he
answered the question no I know I mean
symbols
yeah that's great I mean why wouldn't it
actually I'm sorry I really meant to put
this in but I get clearly I didn't mean
to put it in but it really this also
should work with that ID verse so I I
actually I was going to Bunder the
impression that I just have to under and
underscores and that's good enough yeah
no actually I would I would really like
contribution on that side like just even
like a yell at me kind of contribution
like this sucks because I can't use it
because it doesn't work here that would
be a fantastic thing to know because I
just don't use Taylor stuff in general
but it's clearly a lot of people like to
use it so I would never discount
somebody's like to use something but it
would be neat if they could also work
there and I just I just don't know so
but if anybody could provide not right
now I know you might not want to stand
up in the obvious part yeah
there are some vestiges of bad decisions
that are still there
which I believe will be corrected part
possibly in this new platform and the
platform mind you whatever I do well so
XTS will never die because that would
just be wrong but whatever it is I do
after this is going to be backward
compatible with it there's zero chance
it won't so the idea would be that it
solves the problems that don't that
aren't solved right now or really really
really hard to solve right now and allow
people to move forward without breaking
the old stuff colleague XTS too would be
in like a ggplot sense although that
breaks seventeen that's another talk
yes yes yeah yes I meant to put that in
there too yes correct that is fantastic
tool yeah 100%
yeah 100% thank you from in in this
particular case though they're just
actually changes in level like that the
DIF function yeah it's just changes in
level so the gaps of is there are some
weird cases around that and agree cuz it
the the the how you interpreted it's
actually the plots are the same way that
qua mots were always irregular so just
when the times were represented and then
XTS used to be fixed time so you'd see
the big gaps so a lot of the stuff in
excess is also of that mindset that is
actually changed in the last few years
like 15 I think they added in in XTS
plotting the ability to choose whether
or not you see just the times that are
actually visible or all the regularize
intervals so the same thing there but
that said I think the DIF probably fails
in that regard like it's not it's not
smart enough at the edge cases
so Zoo should be like 100% compatible so
I've worked with I'm like I'm a
co-author on Zoo as well and the idea
was to back port everything from excess
in to zoo that would make it more
high-performance because I hate the fake
word performance also another pet peeve
of mine but so Zoo should be like
drop-in replacement with the exception
of the lag function because there
there's actually a global option you can
set in excess that says like respect the
original version of lag again stupid
decision I but I can't change it I can't
can't break it and Hakeem and I have
agreed for the last decade that you
can't really break things twice so but
it should be genuinely dropping replaced
because I actually use do a hundred
percent
prior the only reason I had to write
excess was because in qua mod if I
wanted to plot things I was I really
wanted to let everyone who had a time
series of all the nine different time
series to be able to use it so I wanted
one thing it was actually internal to
quad originally that did this conversion
and then it just seemed like it had a
lot more value or more value outside as
well
so it became outside but the core of it
is you I mean inherit Zoo it's only over
time that I've picked off little
functions than Zoo to make them more
performance oriented but I got a hundred
percent they should work unless you have
indices that are not time like if you're
indexing by like that the brilliance of
vacuums design or Hakeem and Gabor that
that you could just define this order
function like all caps order and you
could literally have like four to five
seven be the correct order and like as
long as your order function handle that
you could write your code madness
version to be that way and it would all
be ordered and everything would just
work but it also meant it was slow
because kind of it had to accommodate
that so this kind of said nope you're
gonna be time whatever time you want I
don't care cuz they convert it
internally which I don't mention here
but it all gets into convert it
internally to unix-like POSIX et time
although it's not even POSIX et because
that's actually too slow so it is
there's it should work like if you want
to email me that's
I think yeah I think the length I think
the fact that we are now sort of post
language if you will like people just
have to operate across multiple
languages and it will be nice mentally
and I have to learn two different things
like if there could just be one course
e-library that there's some core library
whatever it's written in underneath that
just need everything and expose the same
interface and not from an API standpoint
like I can't send stuff over the wire
that's just it's not there's no way I
can get the same performance over the
wire that I can in embedded situation so
I like mentally I need it to be that way
but I wanted to be across all of the
language lag so lag is obviously
something that you do need in many
things in finance like you may really
want to be very careful finance or any
good domain that you're trying to
predict you don't want to have
accidentally information from the future
so you may want to be just like super
conservative and say I'm going to make
sure I don't even have to date you know
today's data or tomorrow's thing I just
want to be super conservative see what
kind of decay I might have for something
so here it's like it specifies k2 which
I will concede so in time series
literature the this is the correct
generally speaking the correct notation
but the correct notation is a positive
wag value is is this kind of like where
you move ahead effectively in our in
base our it's actually backwards
I don't know why it's because no one in
base are no one in core uses time series
which is kind of why we have TS
somebody was like we need a time series
class best I can tell
so it's backwards so I took upon myself
to say screw that I'm going to fix this
which is a bad call frankly this is me
in 2006 a little more crazy so that
shouldn't be the case it really should
be negative in fact there is a lag TS
and a lead TS in zoo which have never
been exposed but to exist that try and
fix this because we don't want to crush
namespace right namespace should be like
that's the way you expected to work
that's the way it works and that's
whatever and it's crappy it's crappy we
all live with it and move on you can
easily name something else
quantum art actually does lag with a
capital L it's kind of jacked up but it
at least is different and doesn't
doesn't ruin what was there before I
broke the rule here which is I still
feel bad about so but again here K is
the argument positive is leg negative is
lead so you've got a shift then you see
it automatically fills and a you can
change that so to drop it and it's K but
ok so no if I stress this but it's ok
it's really K is the leg in stats since
forever
so lag is on the left here means that's
there might be a lag in deep liar that I
don't know if you could see it but it
doesn't use K juices in and I cannot
tell you how much production code has
broken because somebody loads deep liar
ahead of maybe not even XTS but like
anything it uses regular leg so
admittedly this is from the dawn of time
and this is from 2014 so I don't know
what was going on there but it's not
necessarily what I would have done so
that was my that's my initial reaction
this is just kind of me now
anybody know what this room yes which is
a greatest movie of all time so on a
more rational bit this is just extra
functions again there there XTS tries to
be very very careful and clean there's
no dependency except for zoom because it
extends ooh and it actually uses a whole
bunch of zoo so like just default
methods our zoo so it's really it was
supposed to not use anything of zulu
really supposed to just be like enforced
time or sorry you're suppose to use
everything observed but it was supposed
to enforce time as the index instead of
arbitrary index like 1 2 3 or ABC or
whatever you could do Zoo is amazing but
it's slowly got more and more C code in
it got a little more prescriptive a lot
of the C code has actually been ported
back to the zoo or some of it it's still
on my list for the last decade
that's a kima can shoot occasionally
things beyond when are we doing this but
so last an a last observation carry
forward you kind of can see where like
if you if you've got missing this you
can kind of carry forward easily and
there's other functions in there to do
this but last thing if you notice is
like the one month things just like
splits where you can break things up
easily by that kind of natural language
if you will I think it's a now sorry is
it the second thing I don't like okay I
do like the beats about so the other
thing here is like as one of the other
core functions that you have to do in
anything in data is you're obviously
always joining data together so merge is
the critical function see volume just
kind of the alias here but merge in this
case the default is outer join but it's
it doesn't care about what you're what
you're joining on it's joining on time
so it's unlike kind of data frame which
is a little
crazy in the merge but it this is always
joining on time because time is the most
important thing to get right you can
always fix things after that but you got
to get that thing right first and you
can see you kind of well you may not be
able to see here it's my examples are
not complete but you can see it's kind
of filling in pieces with na s that
didn't exist in the other series so and
again needs to be super fast because you
do it a lot or you're joining really
really big things or certainly needs to
be right but in this case it's all
highly optimized C code
there are north of 7000 lines of C code
and X yes it's principally C code ANSI
like 89 and C code because it's supposed
to be portable it compiles on all of the
our test platforms including Solaris did
any may have died actually solarz died a
test oh sweet okay well mine would still
work don't like new things sorry but
there are other options here there's
like inner join left join right join
they all have but the idea is like you
can do a lot kind of add on the Box
they're all against me for fast I don't
have any performance numbers on that but
the one thing that you and this comes
from zu although it's reimplemented
annex yes is this like notion of you're
doing any ops with the data you needed
to be joined by time you last thing in
the world you want to do is multiply
something from yesterday with today
unless you're intending it and then you
need to exclusively lag it so you make
so it's all very explicit you don't
accidentally get the wrong answer
and because accidentally I mean that
that's devastating it's devastating when
you actually have real money trading and
you could lose millions of dollars
inside of minutes so very very important
not to screw that up so this kind of
like overloading of ops and doing the
right thing even if it's a little
confusing it's x is I think the right
thing to do again inherited from sue
from performance perspective these are
not trivial examples but like if you did
kind of traditional if you forgot about
using or if you decided not to use like
a proper time series class and he was
kind of naively said my index is an ex
ESO support looks like it doesn't care
whatever you do but because it its
backward compatible with old code tries
to be you could say like I want
everything you know I want the end the
last day of the year
in 2019 and in this case ten million
observations not checked antic or a
hundred million observations a little
bit more gigantic but you can do it in a
normal way and if you know are obvious
it's creating a logical vector first and
another logic actually creating yeah
back to vector logical vector another
logical vector yeah it's kind of a mess
like it's making a lot of a lot of data
and just to get an answer so it takes a
long time
xes implements a binary search so it's
actually instantaneously it's constant
and how much you extract so it's just a
copy and it's actually a mem copy so
there's no it's as fast as you can
conceivably get on the kind of good
actually it was well planned not well
rehearsed this is I would say well the
one the bottom one is my doing the top
one is a product of two outstanding
google Summer of Code students over the
last decade or so I basically took the
madness I wrote it's genuine madness I
cannot understand it anymore
in Guam odd the plotting in Guam odd and
ported it over to XTS basically it
provides for like additive style
plotting so you can take some some time
series and then add some function to
Lynette another one to it or a render
something although at the top and they
do actually render separately so you
this is the final product but here like
the nice part is that you get proper
time series plots fairly well annotated
and you can also do kind of
things on top of them or add to them
again this is probably not all that
different in whatever that had reverse
typed ID first I'm sorry
it used to be had reversed a long time
ago actually qualms are plots only
exists because of ggplot because when
you try and render I don't know what
it's like now but if you tried to render
all of those points it could be like
millions of points yeah it takes a long
time it's actually not ggplot fault it
was a great comfort but so here you can
see you like xes now provides kind of
needed functionality to do overlays and
and all with if you've no sorry kind of
neglecting that's everything all with
very core standard function so points
lines things that you kind of should
know or might know just by from an early
introduction to are and they all just
going to magically work there's a little
bit of magic going on which i don't
necessarily like but they do work and
i'm it's my fault so it's no one else to
blame but they do work and it's pretty
neat that you can kind of get these
pretty nice-looking blots that answers
your questions pretty quickly with not
much effort
one day maybe they'll be piped together
i think that would be it
i don't know how to do that though so as
a corollary if you wanted like a genuine
like a traditional time serie or a
traditional financial cloth qualm odd
does this kind of thing with chart
series and all these add underscore
functions which they will continue to
add and you can actually remove them you
can change the scale I can do all that
dynamically these are definitely predate
something that's you know web-based but
but still kind of fun at the time and
still it's super relevant now it still
works but still works
fimA still works so the sure what the
heck why am i so what XD s has been kind
of languishing because I I think I
yelled at Josh too many times about
breaking things actually where somebody
else yelled at him for breaking things
not and it's just like innocuous let's
just make sure that I don't know
something that shouldn't have broken
before now doesn't break and all of a
sudden the Cascades it breaks everything
else so like and when there's so many
people using it for really important
things it's really really hard to break
stuff so you just don't want to break
things consequently all of these things
have been tried over the years I now
have the opportunity to try and make
them actually get into XTS so like an ex
DSS data frame has literally been on
this machine for a decade maybe not done
how old this machine is but so it it's
real edges never getting first poor
taste in pizza
[Music]
Thank You Jared and can everyone
actually hear me I think they okay good
good okay so I will kind of apologize in
advance that I I've been in the industry
for a few years and I've gotten a tiny
bit lazy when it comes to presentations
so for the most part I wouldn't actually
especially something I've talked about
this is probably the 40th talk I've
given around the world on this it gets a
little hard to put these together that
said this is the one I put more time
into then a whole of the rest so it's
plausible it's over in like 15 minutes
but we'll see so but I feel proud of
this one so again Jeff Ryan let me give
it to this so that kind of the five
parts I'll talk about today are
personally Who am I and why the heck do
I care about time series second is why
time series is actually something to
care about which is it genuinely is
different and then kind of touch on more
of where we've been and also not not
just an R but like round R and then give
because Jared had asked sort of a
rundown of xes just in case anybody's
not used it since I realized we live in
a tidy versland
and it's no longer relevant and in the
future and the future is actually the
reason I'm here so hopefully that's
exciting it's exciting to me so without
further ado so Who am I this is me and
like I said it's kind of like a least
mentally I thought it was more like a
two-factor authentication and a slide
deck that is me
so it's also the only good picture I
have of me so there's also there's a
really bad picture that floats around
the internet that's me but it's really
really bad that's me but my background
actually I'm much more diverse
background it's not on the slide deck I
used to do a bunch of like weird I was a
bike mechanic for
long time but after that I ended up
finishing an econ degree in 2004
actually but started using R in 2002 so
that's really really long time in our
space it's really [ __ ] I'm now in any
space that's 17 years ago almost 18
years ago so I really actually I was not
very good at R then but it looked to me
like a it was free and it was something
that looked really powerful even thing
from that point I ended up going 2004 to
be a market maker on the floor of the
Options Exchange in Chicago which is
completely not my personality generally
you need to be much taller much meaner
I'm wait I think I'm too nice and I
don't know maybe yeah that's pretty much
the take of what the people on the floor
were I spend actually most of my time on
the floor the floor I don't fit
anybody's ever worked on the trading
floors anybody worked on the trading
floors so not that yes I am told people
my first day on the floor was quite
amusing because I kind of thought it to
be this like magical realm of you know
I've seen it in all the movies and
thought that was the neatest thing in
the world but when I got it down so you
go from the like a members lounge down
to the floor and I was out of bad now
we've got like what about all the state
of the world outside of our and maybe
not just then but like now there's a
whole bunch of things that claim to be
time series databases mind you in 2010
there were approximately like three and
know there are everything on earth
claims it to be a time series database
which is puzzling to me again
because they're mostly time stamps but
they do and it's kind of a hot topic so
but you do see like some of the cooler
ones I think friends of mine like time
scale time stream influx certainly has a
lot of market share
Katie B is bellwether rock star database
costs a lot of money that Kitty B's kind
of AD and put this for data table was
free but they're all really neat in
there oh really
Solutions but they're not the same
they're not like you can't use them in
the language there there's some extra
system that you need to build or
maintaining or whatever in the outside
of that or inside of a language there
was pandas came about and Julia time
arrays and Julia DB both or all of these
are actually I was going to paste the
emails but they're all directly derived
from XDS so and the idea was it's not
actually a set XTS is derived from a zoo
and zoos arrived from TS like they're
all established provenance of like we
just need one little feature beyond what
was there before
and so XE has kind of was like I tried
to make everything work but it wasn't
like there were some revolutionary
pinyin there although I did make it
faster so that was helpful but again
nothing revolutionary I just kind of
kept on building on what other people
did and same thing a pandas like Python
now has that Julian as agile a DB and to
that point if you go look at the julia
DB which they used to be like a generic
time series database or database if you
will and it now would know it seems to
be only like accessible from Julia
they're very they've kind of changed our
model I believe a little bit but they
they obviously seem to think they are
way better than us but that's okay
because literally they're competing
against twelve-year-old version of us
which is fine because that's why I
that's why I left where I left cuz I
don't I can't take this so but it turns
out they did leave one metric off of
there which is they really don't have
any kudos to Wesson and the pandas team
though they they're rock stars so okay
so now I guess the meat of if you've
never used actually how many people are
actually used exist anybody anybody
all right so decent issue number people
wait
I'm what do you pronounce it Sybil Sybil
Sybil how many people have used Sybil
okay I'm still winning
okay so XTS what the heck is it it's
actually super duper simple and it's the
same as you well slightly different but
there is a there's a matrix they're all
matrix objects and this is cause problem
for the last twelve years and I agree to
we have actually I have code from 2009
that I worked with Aki manana on that
was to get rid of just the matrix
concept but the problem is TS is a
matrix and or mts is a matrix and zu is
a matrix and pretty much every modelling
function you would apply it to in our
consumes a matrix at its core like
you're not doing math on characters so
like distilled down you want numbers and
that's kind of what matrices are good
for so there was never really a crazy
need for it but I get it and I've I also
have hijacked XDS to make it work for
character stuff so those are bad
solutions like there needs to be a
better solution I'll get to that thinner
but underscore two matrix and then
there's an attribute that's the top and
it's not visible in the matrix it's not
part of the matrix but is just so much
extra attribute there could be multiple
ones of these but at present there's
there's one vector of time it's ordered
etc and it's consumed internally and
then there's also this like user
attribute that I have needed to have
this so like data provenance I needed
kind of like I got this data at this
point in time and I need to know that
that's when it was so maybe I can age it
or or purchase or whatever but those
things I wanted to be carried with the
object in most everything you do or
everything else as soon as you subset
something it's gone right it's a
different object and all the attributes
are gone so this thing kind of is a
little bit smarter as a basic tutorial
of how to use this is it's super simple
and all the credit to this one oh this
is oh sorry I'll have another pizza
thing
that's good check one for joke okay so
yes no that's actually what Pizza should
be no I'm just kidding but D is pretty
good pizza what's not no camera thing I
don't normally talk on a camera so the
way but if you notice here that the
actual arguments here aside from pizza
and language are the way that TS is
built like there it's this is the way
our was done so if you understood are
it's very easy to use ooh and then this
was just like it's a it's a super set of
zoom essentially but and then these
other things are kind of the extra
attributes that I wanted to carry along
so arbitrary what are they on that if
you notice on the other side though
there's this this index function and it
could be time again these are from stats
the our stats package ts index it's just
that's the way it was not our creation
Natsu's creation this is like respecting
the way our built it and so everyone who
could migrate easily into this tool to
get back out the raw data throw away the
object core data again this comes from
zoo but XDS attributes would be the only
access component here and again like
these are things that I want to know
like I want to know the expiration
expert of this particular series or or
that when to roll the future or
something and these things stick around
so you can bind them together and all of
a sudden you know the provenance of
where you're at so it's pretty helpful
in practice up and down like how hard is
that the there are some I kind of there
are a lot of helper functions in the
package that are just like really
annoying things to have to calculate so
again they're just provided for
simplicity purposes they're not
necessarily perfect but they do a very
good job
so like periodicity will kind of tell
you like how and there's scales from
everything from in Italy all the way out
to you earlier
probably just yearly but you can also
nicely cast these
and again you can see my finance
background of I want to take out a
univariate series and turn it into a
multivariate series and with some sort
of like logical open high/low close
or there's another range bar kind of
thing and again like periodicity etc
works on this stuff if you notice I
comment that they're well tested and
stable there are two proofs of this one
is well tested is if wrong someone
emails me at 3:00 in the morning and
stable is proven because again if it's
broken someone emails me at 3:00 in the
morning so both of those things are like
they are the reason xes does not move
very frequently it's it's meant to be
used by people running literally adders
like I can guarantee you there are
trillions of dollars a year traded
through this software and it's you can't
break that stuff so it's static if you
will people think it's not updated
whatever it is just we don't break
things yeah leave it again so again some
more helpful function so these are
really really cool are functions like if
you know are if you know base are you
know kind of just general concepts of
our that these things just work but they
kind of again they're slightly they're
meant to be generic so they're applied
as generics but here you can say like
split this data set by month or by week
or day and it's even a little bit
further where you can say split this
thing every three days or every four
weeks or whatever some arbitrary
cut-offs and you can kind of mix and
match them and do some pretty neat stuff
to very quickly break them up by time
and be assured that you have broken them
up correctly by time because it's very
very very easy to screw up subsetting in
XTS is probably the my only contribution
in the world the last three kids do so
but this is one thing that's definitely
been used by Python and whatever has
come after is this notion of like really
just direct character subsetting based
on ISO 8601 which anybody know ISO 8601
format okay yeah so it's basically it is
the I've just flat out it's the right
way to represent them there's just no
two ways about it
anything else is wrong which I say that
about a lot of things but this one is
true so it's basically like these are
actually represent intervals and for
instance this one is October of nineteen
and pretty straightforward very readable
very developer friendly very analyst
friendly you can't screw that up
you really can't screw it up and what
this one actually does is it says like
even though it doesn't look like an
interval it doesn't have like a start
and an end it auto magically says it
takes both of them and it perturbs the
one to be the end of that interval so
you get that the thing you wanted so
here October of this series this this is
just eight literally goes from the 24th
so and then the next one you can see a
little more or a little different he's
basically this little slash says give me
everything from this point in time until
the end of your data set which is super
handy when you don't know when the end
of your data set is so you could test it
or you could say there's a whole bunch
of ways to kind of go about it but
they're really clunky and they're also
not fast so this is fast which I'll get
to you could do something like I want 26
to the 28th it also does this kind of
extrapolation of your your specification
these are all ISO standard it actually
apply like it takes the full iso
standard and applies it inside of this
object there may be some problems if you
ever encounter a problem email me
because it should not exist these things
have been tested for a decade and
they're clearly the edge cases that
people don't care about maybe you're
used but if they're wrong they're wrong
and that's not cool
I'll fix that but you can see here I
like just get me the day get me all the
way through this day whatever the series
is again ISO 8601 my favorite thing
right it's got to be my favorite
standard in the world frankly it also
cost money to get the standard you know
that's crazy I know that's a racket so
but don't ever do like 3 to 17 I don't
know how many times I've seen that but I
don't know what that even means there's
at March 2nd is it March 17th I don't
even know so bad bad bad plus it's not
sortable you can't there you can't sort
them so whereas the first former is
sortable very nicely like official
market maker and they have the base of
the escalator a stack of crossword
puzzles and it was literally like
everyone was taking them and people
would just do the crossword puzzle
pretty much most of the day because
there's really just like the open lunch
and clothes and the rest of the day was
more or less nothing happening and at
the time it was actually a lot of
electronic market making and in the
option space it was kind of most of
things were trade on the screen so you
really didn't even get to participate in
trades I did not do the crossword
puzzles I actually spent time learning
are somewhat proud of myself but lots of
things we're not proud of but that one
I'm more proud of in 2006 I had already
left the floor and was trading on my own
turned out I still like to are and the
thing with our though was at that point
in time there weren't a lot of tools
around there were I think there might
even like 300 ish packages now there was
15,000 or something so not a lot of
tools and there was like t-series pretty
much t-series so we were missing a lot
in the finance realm so I wrote and
decided to publish because actually good
friends of mine who are not good friends
at the time but happen to live down the
street
we're bryan peterson peter caro who
wrote performance analytics and and got
a butyl doll is also in chicago but like
we all accidentally
were local friends unbeknownst to each
other but I decided because they had all
contributed stuff I wanted to contribute
stuff so I did
so qua mod XD s were born Josh Ulrich is
also a key component of these things at
the early days actually a lot cuz he was
working for a different company he was
an incredible sounding board so all of
my ideas he would shoot down and then we
ended up with good stuff so after doing
working on that releasing that I ended
up coming up with the idea but there are
also a whole bunch of people at this at
the start of our finance that we ended
up getting dirk and brian and peter and
josh and multiple other people in 2009
which i believe is probably the second
major maybe even just a second now i
guess the second major our conference in
our third major our conference in the
world at that point we've been doing it
now this is the 12th year coming up in
chicago i would show you the website but
uh it's actually on me to make the new
one and clearly it is not done in spite
of me being taunted by the rest of the
committee so but it's a really good show
if you like finance is a great place to
be just even job in general are as great
in 2013 I kind of left the open source
realm and went to work as a quant for
City know where I stayed for what is
more or less six years and now I decided
like I need to do what I liked to do
before which is basically write open
source software write code that other
people use and write things that other
people get to see at the very least so
why time series it turns out my time sir
is really hard to get right
it just it's not like regular data it's
there's a whole bunch of pieces to it
and not only is it really hard to like
even put together it turns out it's
super easy to mess up and messing up in
finance is like look ahead is
devastating you could spend months and
all of a sudden you realize you screwed
one of the times up and you're just
cheating so all of a sudden all of your
results are garbage and you're just
trading noise so that's not good and
then I'm kind of the bonus is that it
turns out
like maybe everything in the world is
the time series like everything happens
in time so that's good
so now why is time series different so
these are kind of a take away that I've
figured out too over time no definitely
no pun intended firstly is that
regardless of again what you're what
you're capturing every single
observation has some sort of time
associated with it and and they're also
generally speaking you can't change them
they're immutable like it happened it
happened there's no going back and
fixing that it happened maybe you need
to fix the value but that didn't happen
before and this is kind of a surreal
thing because I have encountered so many
especially data vendors that don't quite
grasp that and I think the best data is
the one that's been corrected and that
that's just garbage that's messing up
the times again so you really really
need to be cognizant of like that time
that exists and you really need a tool
that manages that component without
extra logic because that's where you can
screw it up in addition to not only just
like they come in you also may get
things that happen at the same time just
your resolution in time doesn't quite
work and my kind of side note at the
bottom that I understand it was if it
doesn't have a time Sam doesn't mean
it's not a time series it just you don't
have the timestamp you lost some of the
data time scales in time series are
crazy they could go from like geological
sort of scale like the beginning of time
all the way down to or up to picoseconds
and in finance like just ridiculous
stuff like that hardware is the only way
you can measure it the vote is really
neat these I remember reading a story I
couldn't find the source of the story so
I'm just trying to find a picture but
Ellison has on their boat because
obviously he's got fancy databases and
billions of dollars actually that might
be his boat but he actually no but they
are I mean they're measuring like thirty
thousand observations a second and
actually every one of the crew literally
has sensors or reporting devices that
can tell them
happening at that moment in time and
this applies that pretty much everything
with formula one any any high-end sport
pretty neat I really like that aspect
I'm kind of a competitive person the
second thing that I noticed here is that
they don't actually happen it's like
fixed intervals and the previous
incarnations of time series in in most
software really think it happens at
fixed intervals like they're just kind
of this the old stuff used to be it
happens at this time horizon and that's
it but things happen at any horizon at
any granularity or whatever we managed
to measure and you can see like I mean
even if you even if you think and this
this kind of also illustrates the fact
that there's a time that it happens and
time you thought it was gonna happen or
a time that is valid from there's a
whole bunch of like time components but
those time components are still really
there's only one really one thing
associated with that observation in time
and that that's kind of the timestamp it
happened so the rest I think for
attributes personally the crazier part
is this stuff we we have time zones
right there's there's something actually
I had to look this up there are 38 time
zones which of course makes no sense
because there are only 24 hours but
there there are 38 of them which because
there are time zones that are 30 minute
increments like 30 minutes off or 15
minutes off is that 14 yeah that's just
madness right yeah I was that what
you're can you see that okay and then
but then we also have like daylight
savings time which is is completely
arbitrary this is like up to whatever
local council decides to decide to set
their clocks back or forward or whatever
this actually changes so we luckily have
zone info database which kind of keeps
track of this stuff but it's madness
it's the one extra piece of the puzzle
you've to keep track of and then we also
have things that might matter to you or
your domain which in this case your
calendars and again could be like
exchange calendars is the options
Clearing Corp calendar of expirations
four options
and all the different types of options
you have now and you have daily options
too so I guess that's every day there
but then you have holidays and whatever
else you might have to employ so all
those things have to somehow be
accounted for in the software the crazy
part of this was like as I thought about
it was like holy crap the time zones are
a time series like you can't even you
couldn't even like specify a time zone
because it may disappear at some point
in the past or in the future so it's a
whole it's really messy so all of that
has to be included in what you do with
your object so like everything you have
to do multiplication
whether you're merging whether you're
whatever subsetting it you need to be
cognizant of this this peculiarity of
time and maybe it's just like in XTS
this case we reduce it down to sort of a
common time like UTC time because really
there is only one point of time in the
universe so it's not actually that hard
but you do need to translate them so but
I guess the point of that is just adding
a timestamp to your data frame isn't
going to cut it unless you've got a heck
of a lot of logic around there so kind
of that past in present take phrase days
so this was a long time ago as evidenced
by that fun t-rex
right Connor is more fun than you guys
did obviously so there's TS and then mts
I don't think there's a soul on earth
yes but but TS is also not really very
useful though it is I don't understand
not now people who use like like
certainly a regular yeah I mean we all
know there's no names just a dinosaur so
but these are it turns out it's really
not anytime things right it's like it's
frequency please so it's like happens
here happens again here happens again
here happens again here that doesn't
work very well if you deal with kind of
real data coming from either monitoring
equipment or finance
my general realm so post that we there
was like this kind of explosion predate
the dinosaurs technically but that we
just all of a sudden had all of these
which was kind of madness the ones
highlighted that I highlighted are the
ones that most people tended to use but
there doesn't mean that the other ones
didn't exist and they they all had
genuine application and a lot of users
so it was really an excess Scottish
shoehorned in there but this was like a
very real problem somewhere in like 2006
2007 2008 that you had to kind of figure
out how the heck you if you're gonna
write something how do you cope with all
of this you can mandate that your users
use it some particular subset of this
but that's I'm generally a bad strategy
certainly for adoption I'm kinda want to
be super flexible so XTS and I came
along and said I need to write stuff for
everyone to use and it's got to take all
of these things into account which is a
mess and then let me just point out this
is mind boggling to me but ten years
later I'm being kind these two new ones
show up I don't know why but they they
kind of do most of the same thing but I
have not used them so let me just caveat
I'm probably missing something I'm weak
I'm kind of like this game so so this
well it's not order because you can see
why I need a time series class but this
is the the original versions I grabbed
from the archive on cran of when these
things showed up and some of them show
up in like some of them genuinely
existed in packages or only existent
packages does not stand alone but these
things are pretty old
and but you can kind of see like there
was a problem with handling regular
interval time series and it needed to be
it's like people just needed their
regular time series but they all made
reared assumptions like some of them had
you had to use POSIX some of them you
had to use dates some of them had use
cron so that was our